es ist wirklich eine zeit in der es
nichts zu feiern gibt und in der wir
versuchen müssen jetzt die
infektionszahlen würden sie jetzt raten
schon mal einzuladen oder auch gerade
das einmal ich würde jetzt erst einmal
raten dass wir das noch einige wochen
ertragen und dass wir jetzt alles daran
setzen dass diese situation eintritt die
wir uns wünschen dass eine entspannung
gibt und dass wir vielleicht auch
maßnahmen über die weihnachtsfeiertage
machen können die etwas stärker einer
anderen bereich zurück bringen und dann
vielleicht ermöglichen dass wir
einigermaßen dass das weihnachtsfest
feiern können aber es bleibt bei dieser
erkenntnis dass gerade familien feiern
ja dadurch gekennzeichnet ist dass die
ältere generation mit der jüngeren
zusammenkommt und da sind wir wieder in
diesem dilemma dieses virus das ist ja
kein problem der regierung oder der
verordnung dieses virus hat diese
eigenschaft dass es die ältere
generation so gefährdet und alle anderen
aber die übertragung machen können wir
haben ja viele erkenntnisse was wirklich
etwas bringt und was wir vielleicht aus
mehreren schritten
das ist noch mal so es gibt viele
sitzungen haben die haben wir einfach im
frühjahr getroffen auf auf dringende
empfehlung der virologen und der
wissenschaftler war noch zu wenig
bekannt war zum beispiel haben wir ja
angenommen dass die kleinsten kinder
also kindergärten geschlossen werden
müssen spielplätze nicht benutzt werden
sollten
nein das ist etwas was ich nicht
bestätigt hat was mittlerweile erkannt
wurde das heißt das schließe das ist ja
was ganz wichtig ist erwarten wir im
moment millionen deutsche mit ihren
kindern darauf zu hause mit sicherheit
zu haben okay das passiert in den
nächsten wochen in schulen und kitas
also sie würden für hamburg sprechen
dafür hamburg für hamburg werden sie
sagen geht das auf keinen fall
nein das ist jedenfalls etwas was wir
jetzt wissen dass das nicht so
empfindlich ist wie die andere bereiche
und wir haben wie gesagt die spielplätze
unter freiem himmel geschlossen und
irgendwer festgelegt da gab es keine das
passiert nicht noch mal
das ist jedenfalls nicht das was jetzt
was jetzt bevorsteht als nächster
schritt sondern wir würden wenn wir ein
weiterer schritte benötigen würden wir
in den bereichen beginnen wo wir auch
wissen dass dort infektionsrisiken
liegen ist will ich kapiere sonnig
wiederholt sich nun der märz oder ist
das ein was die situation im märz will
das sich so nicht wiederholen weil wir
neue erkenntnisse haben und wissen dass
bestimmte dinge einfach gar nicht wirken